so excited this is my first ever
fellow crater lunch date and i cannot
wait
[Music]
so i am super excited to be hanging out
with one of my favorite content creators
who just happens to also be here in
toronto
um i'm actually going away next week to
new york for a special secret project
that i'm really excited about oh little
kid don't want to hit you oh my god all
right so i need to pick up some
groceries for my family and i figured
like what better place to do it than at
my local farmers market so i am going to
be meeting jacqueline forbes at uh the
beautiful brickworks market we're gonna
do a little shopping we're gonna have a
little lunch we're gonna spill a little
tea
hopefully iced tea though because it is
like hot as [ __ ] out here let's do it
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor element so you guys know i
review a lot of fitness creators and
athletes here at abby's kitchen and one
of the biggest nutrition mistakes that
my sports rd colleagues and i see is not
properly rehydrating when extra
hydration is indicated for a lot of
people plain water is just fine but for
folks doing longer higher intensity
workouts exercising in the heat or who
are just what we like to call salty
sweaters there's definitely a role for a
well-balanced electrolyte replacement so
when i pulled my sports rd colleagues a
lot of them told me that element was
their personal go-to product because it
has a science-backed electrolyte ratio
of a thousand milligrams of sodium 200
milligrams potassium and 60 milligrams
of magnesium it also has no added sugar
coloring gluten artificial sweeteners or
other ingredients for folks who are
extra sensitive and it's been the go-to
electrolyte replacement for us olympians
special forces and other professional
athletes i myself am not doing any
strenuous activity right now but i did
use this product when i was nursing and
pumping because i felt i was having a
hard time keeping up with the hydration
demand and the dietitian that i work
with now actually recommended it to me
as part of my supplement regimen to help
support my anxiety and sleep related
struggles all the flavors are super
delicious but i am low-key obsessed with
the mango chili so if you want to give
element a try you can get a whole sample
pack of eight different flavors with any
element purchase check out the link in
the description to get yours
[Music]
you look so adorable this hat is
everything thank you nice to meet you in
real life
so fun what a gorgeous day hello camera
beautiful day apologies for the audio it
is so busy in here and loud but that's
kind of just part of the experience it
is a party i hope we can hear us we'll
start yelling
okay so i'm obsessed with the petrol oh
baby i'm a bread girlie like bread is my
favorite food
can i get a bet a bag of chocolate
please thank you i will definitely do
some sour dough are they all vegan
friendly
[Music]
and that way i can't have soda i get
anything carbonated i have to have
everything carbonated brony knows
i love it but it's terrible for my teeth
i do find it's like different yeah i saw
a tick tock and it was saying if you
have tons of carbonated water it's like
gives you cavities or something which i
thought it like does erode your like
teeth over time
so you have to be some of them
have like a higher or lower ph than
others yeah like there are brands that
are like better or worse
right um but if i'm having a sensitive
tv i cannot have it i'm interested yeah
oh it's crazy that just like triggered
my memory to the tick tock trend of the
ball's damage
i see you do a video on that something
is so wrong about that trend i did well
i took one sip of that and the
combination of sparkling water with the
balsamic my teeth hurt for like three
days that's actually my worst nightmare
first of all fizzy drink no with just
straight up vinegar in it it was a hard
class like no i don't believe the treads
okay it didn't taste like coke and it
also like hurt like
there was no benefit
[Music]
vegan momos with the vegan pasta
yeah no problem okay
i go through kimchi way too much like
too quickly so
maybe this will be my saturday regular
stuff and also we don't use any of the
fish stock yeah so it's a very basic one
yeah
but you'll love it awesome well honestly
i don't eat fish so it's kind of hard to
find a good kimchi without it
[Music]
[Music]
so we got a few vegan specials here from
the market a couple patties i think
there's like a chickpea one
chickpea chickpea curry chickpea curry
chickpea a faux beef and a
barbecue jackfruit which should be good
these are vegan momos and they're kind
of like a little dumpling i've never had
it before so i'm so excited and then
these are some vegan noodles and pickles
to go with it i'm very excited are you
done oh i'm ready i'm ready i'm always
ready okay i'm gonna do this with a pork
i don't know if this is the right way to
eat this but
oh wow
like cabbage inside
oh this is good
it's momo i've never had this wow i love
the dough yeah dough like dough and
bread like that is my one thing
and
so so we're my favorite food texture is
like anything mushy like a bit like as
if i'm
you know with dentures and maybe i'm
like my 70s
oatmeal
soups
dips like anything that's mushy and
requires no chewing favorite food
texture right there me too this
qualifies for sure this works so
for folks who um
you know don't know you you obviously
are you're vegan you plant-based you
know how was that journey for you like
when did that start and and how do you
like identify in terms of like you're
you're vegan yeah
well it's so interesting so i feel like
even the vegan scene online has changed
so much over the past like 10 years um i
initially was vegetarian ever since i
was a kid i don't know what it was i
can't even explain i just had this
innate feeling i was like mom i don't
want to eat meat i think it also might
have been from there's this merry kid in
ashley olsen episode where one of them
was vegetarian i'm a vegetarian you
should have thought of that before you
decided to come on yo ladies
do we need a time out here they're so
impactful yes like the influence they've
had on me
i remember i think it was called the
challenge it was like a survivor-esque
type movie
and then they all handed her like the
lettuce and they took off the beef it
was this cool thing so maybe it was that
and that subconsciously made me be like
i should be vegetarian i don't know why
from a young age it always was that way
and my parents always were so good at
like you know making homemade meals for
us but they just grew up eating like the
traditional canadian kind of diet or
american diet whatever you want to call
it and i was making grade like four but
i was like mom i don't want to eat meat
anymore she's like no you're a growing
girl you got to make sure you eat all
your nutrients and it's funny now
because she's actually vegan as well but
at the time she just there was no
information around that and there also
just wasn't very as many like products
and options for sure even in the past
five years like it's so much more
convenient for me to just be out of a
random restaurant and be able to eat
something versus just a salad just like
a salad a boring salad pasta with
like tomato sauce yeah i'll try it for a
month and then it like it's been almost
10 years now so i feel really lucky and
i don't i always say this i don't
necessarily
i don't know if it's for everyone i have
no background in any of this stuff i
just do it works for me i get my blood
tested my levels are good i eat all my
colorful vegetables and i try to eat a
balanced diet but for me it's worked and
i feel great doing it i mean i always
say like i have a very strong feeling
that my own children are going to become
oh really
really they love animals and my son
always asks me questions about like like
jerky for example like how where does
the jerky come from right and i said
well that one came from a cow how do
they get the cow in the jerky well they
have to slaughter the cow and then they
he says well what happens to
the mommy and daddy like he'll ask like
those kinds of questions or the babies
the babies
and like i i'm really like all about
parenting honestly so i try to be open
and and of course he's going to make his
decision on on what he wants to do as he
gets older um and uh and i'm totally
supportive of that totally no we ate a
lot of pancake foods anyway so it would
be a natural thing for our family to do
for sure um but yeah i think that thank
goodness over the past 10 years we've
seen such an evolution in the vegan
space i'm curious did you ever feel like
you wanted to dabble in some of the more
kind of like fringe extreme aspects of
veganism oh absolutely so when i first
went vegan and this was a time of like
the fruitarian raw vegan which that's
what i understood veganism to be
and it's funny because i had started
posting on youtube around this time when
i was 16 when i started posting i'm 24
now and my first videos i like i
literally have like three mangoes for
like a dessert or a snack whereas now
again like i love a mango it's my
favorite fruit but i just have like one
now but at the time i saw all of these
vegans who were like the face of the
community
yes and they were eating so much fruit
so it was so funny i had this specific
memory i was doing cheerleading at the
time and i was going away on this trip
and i was again still like newly kind of
vegan but eating a lot more fruit yeah i
wouldn't i was never like raw vegan or
properly that level but i eat much more
fruit and then that's actually why i
started posting a lot of what i eat in a
days because i wasn't seeing anyone just
eating quote-unquote quote normal vegan
yes and making not making you feel like
oh you're bad if you use oil or if you
eat bread like all of these things oil
free vegan the high carb low fat vegan
that to me
is such a problematic yes
element of that space because it really
has
encouraged a lot of people to have these
really like disordered
kinds of yeah
you know veganism can can and should be
absolutely a balanced way of eating oh
for sure but when you are like
purposefully cutting out all of these
already vegan foods it's like you're not
left with very much oh and not for what
reason and that's what makes me kind of
sad in the sense that i felt like i was
i mean
as smart as you can be at 15 or 16 and i
always came from a background like you
know very balanced eating so if i was
even falling susceptible to that at that
time and all of the vegan icons were
eating this way like how can you not
think that that's the right way to eat
my own
younger years when i'm struggling with
my relationship food and i don't think
that my parents really knew but they
were like trying to support me and made
me feel comfortable but at the same time
i think that they were like
is this going too far because you know
like i had orthorexia which is like
basically me wanting to be healthy but
taking it to an extreme and so at first
they were like oh this is like healthy
behavior right there's a good intention
but then like once they started to see
it have such a big impact on my physical
and mental health they were like oh no
did like to be
a little beef patty
it's good
spicy i love a good spice flaky
[Music]
it's actually like miraculously nice how
like there's so many great innovative
plant-based restaurants now that are
playing with all these great vegetables
and i love that like i the one of my
favorite restaurants i think it's in
philly it's called veg
um
feel your boss awesome anyways
someone will call me out on it but
anyways it was like one of the i went
there like maybe like 10 years ago
before the vegan movement really took
off and i was just so amazed by it
because it wasn't so much just like you
know using a lot of soy products or like
soy products it was like how do we take
vegetables and make them the star of the
plate right and that to me is like so
interesting oh yeah you know you can
make a personal look and taste like a
scallop for example and like you know
wasted mushrooms yeah like i just i love
like why can't we just like celebrate
all those amazing vegetables more often
and there comes a point where it's like
i can only have so many beyond burgers
yeah in my life like and i think it is
great that there are options again if
you're at a fast food a w it's nice that
i can have an option and not feel like i
can't join in on the activity of eating
or a meal
but there is a point where also again
with the intention of my what i eat a
day videos too is to show that you also
if you want to be eating that all day
you totally can but also it doesn't have
to just be eating mock me because i know
that can also turn people off they'll go
why would i eat plant-based if i'm
eating
food that is acting like what i'm
supposed to avoid it's this whole thing
yeah anyways what you want what you feel
like that's the motto
yeah i'm like eva feels good to you i
think like
that's like for a lot of people they
don't even um
they they're just kind of copying what a
lot of other creators are putting out
there online so funny too because with
youtube it's like your video where you
literally have gone to school for this
you have an actual basis in this
that is put on the same scale and on the
same platform as someone who doesn't but
they could be claiming all of these yep
other things and how does the viewer
necessarily especially if they're
younger know how to navigate they don't
and that's why that's what gets scary it
gets scary i get dozens and dozens and
dozens of dms every single week of
people saying i'm so confused yeah you
know i read this i saw this on youtube i
saw this on tick tock and i don't know
what to believe
and i get it like some of these claims
and these influencers are so
convincing in their you know in their
delivery and their marketing of these
messages that it's literally impossible
to know what to believe and what not to
the layperson is not trained in how to
analyze scientific literature right um
so you know without someone like myself
or other kind of science communicators
we need to help break that down to let
people know
what kind of claims are worth you kind
of thinking more seriously about right
and what is just probably not really
realistic right a lot of the things that
influencers say online are based on like
a smidgen of scientific truth that gets
extrapolated to a point where it
actually no longer makes any kind of
real sense in the real world
so you might see research that's like
done in a petri dish or a single
nutrient but we don't just eat single
nutrients we eat food right and so
unless you're just like
shooting yourself up with an individual
nutrient the likelihood is you're not
going to see any major kind of impact
right on long-term health so
[Music]
bobby's been doing this for like a
really long time
how have you been able to just like
protect your mental health because
there's just so many you know there's a
lot of criticism everyone is really
negative to say do you read comments do
you watch videos about you like how do
you manage that for yourself interesting
part of it is i feel like i'm really
lucky that i'm just somewhat resilient
and do not really care what people think
i think it might have been growing up in
the acting world and just having a
really healthy relationship with
rejection for feedback
um something that i heard though which i
do always try to think about even when
it comes to positive comments too
because also i don't want to be someone
that's getting so full of myself or
these people are hyping me up so it's
like you have to really remember whether
it be positive or negative you really
just can't let either side affect you
so i truly do just try to ignore it and
i also think too for the most part i'd
say like 98 of my comments and the poor
people watching my videos
they
are totally fine and lovely also too
there's a certain point where you see
the same type of maybe negative comments
so like it's like okay if someone gets a
bit more creative or niche and i go okay
you know what that actually like prompts
you that was a bit better like i
appreciate it but there's a certain
point where it's like okay you call me
ugly call me like there's a it doesn't
do too much i think it's more people
like from my real life or people that i
value if they were saying negative
things that would hurt more but it's
like user one two five three oh like
there's a certain point where i don't
and for the most part people are
positive that's right so that i feel
lucky with response videos though i do
kind of get a bit
like you get that feeling right before
you click on it yeah and to be fair
there's only been a few there was a few
that were like very um harsh and i was
like oh okay they were calling me like a
fake vegan that i was lying and like
that i like just like just really mean
stuff i don't even want to like add feel
like don't eat don't go and google the
video don't give them views yeah
so if i had that same feeling with yours
i was like oh god like i'm not even
trying to be like a food person and now
i'm getting these reviews what's going
on but i also think it is healthy to
have criticism too and not being an echo
chamber be like what i'm doing is always
right like i think it is healthy to look
at that stuff um to a degree but yeah
again i just feel lucky that it's never
been too overwhelming and i feel like i
have really healthy boundaries in my
personal life like i'm not the type as
much as i love taking photos and sharing
my life like when i'm living my best
life like my phone isn't out my camera's
not out all those moments i'm very good
at having harsh lives about that's what
about you how do you deal with all that
yeah i mean it's a combination of having
like a really great team who's able to
just like support me and like filter it
through almost through and like yeah if
it's worth me actually taking action
which sometimes it is and like obviously
like acknowledging it i take people's
feedback very seriously
and i do try to integrate that into you
know future
content especially if it's like a long
time viewer someone actually gets you
like yeah that's where i want it that's
the only those are the people that i
actually care about the feedback
the people who don't agree with what i'm
doing they're never gonna agree with
what i'm doing right and i'm not gonna
my content's just not for them right but
it's the people who
the comments from people who are like i
normally love your video but i don't
didn't like about this or i wish you
didn't say that or you should have said
this those are the things that help me
reflect and and get better for next time
right and so those are the comments that
i actually pay more attention to but um
you know i also don't really type a
personality and it is very hard
sometimes to just kind of like
constantly get that bombarding criticism
so
if it's a if it's a critique piece that
i see that it's from somebody who like
i do not give a [ __ ] what they have to
say
i don't even entertain it totally um i
don't even watch it and there's lots of
pieces about me and most of my team will
watch it and they'll be like that was
hilarious abby yeah don't worry about it
yeah it's so funny i watched back my old
videos because again i was like 16 when
i started and it's so funny because now
i look back i'm like what i want my 16
year old kid like posting videos on the
internet that seems so crazy
but i was really lucky too and i have to
give credit to my parents because at
that age
they were
always super protective even about what
i shared online and they would always at
first would always review my youtube
videos before i was allowed to post them
it's at the time when i'm 16 i'm like
i'm grown that's annoying i don't want
to do that mom but i look back i'm so
grateful that i had really good healthy
boundaries with social and also someone
who was
putting a watchful eye on it
um
which i feel like also helped that i was
like i felt like i was really slowly
eased into the world and i say this all
the time to about like take talkers that
i see that will blow up overnight
i feel very grateful that with my career
even when i was younger when i started
going online it was always very gradual
and i got to get my footing in a really
healthy way i was never just thrown in
front of all these you know a huge
audience
so i got to you know make some mistakes
or learn or pivot or be more careful
with what i say or what i like i got to
learn all of that like within time oh
this is like dripping on me yup i know
sam but um yeah i don't know it's
interesting the internet is such an
interesting space and i don't think it's
for everyone it can be really hard and
oh yeah but there's also so many
positive
things that it's changed my life and i
would not take any of it back yeah oh my
god santa mango we're going down it's
going down i know we have we're just so
good so so so sweet and good so i wanted
to ask you about like you know we would
be talking about social media and how
kind of manufactured it often is like do
you ever feel pressure whether it's from
like your wedding days or just like your
day in the lives or like any of the vlog
content you do to like kind of you know
tweak or massage or like
make it make your life a little more
aesthetically pleasing to kind of fit
the youtube aesthetic totally i actually
felt that was something i want to eat in
a days it's kind of what we're talking
about earlier in the sense that i was
like oh what are i was trying to
anticipate what the comments would be
so i would like to be like okay well
let's let me just make my oatmeal let me
play it a bit better let me do a little
yeah and to be fair i love a good plated
meal like i like getting having the art
of like food and things like that so i
like things looking pretty but there's
certain times where i just slap together
a sandwich or i don't worry about like
my plate i will cut on my plate and make
them like i don't worry about those
things but when i am filming i'll be
like okay let me just use a cutting
board that way when i played it it's
more clean like little things like that
yeah because
influencers or content creators like we
are
just normal people totally and i think
that's why people like to watch our
content because they can relate to us so
once we lose that relatability because
we're just like artificially inflating
our lives in certain ways um
i just for me it loses its allure well
i'm just so
excited that
i'm glad this happened thank you for
making the food review first or else i
don't think this would have happened
well i'm i'm thank you for eating
for me
well i'm totally like obsessed with all
your makeup videos because i'm like yeah
girl how do you contour oh you don't
have to come to the studio i'll do it
one day that is that's our next video
okay let's do it
oh you're you're hearing it here so it
will happen yes pulled us accountable
amazing thank you so much for having me
today this is so fun so nice meeting you
too i hope you enjoy your little pretzel
oh i got i got sourdough i got pretzel i
got kimchi actually you got that i hope
it doesn't spill in your bag right now
it's going to be an amazing meal you
showed me that you showed me all the
ways in the market and if you're in
toronto if you do not know about this
come it's a great budget the brickworks
absolutely you might see us there again
every saturday baby
that was so nice to be like just hanging
out with another human because honestly
my job is
usually pretty lonely and especially
with like the whole covid thing over the
past two years
i have been very close to burning out on
more than one occasion
so i'm really trying to make an effort
to find more ways to just like
make my job more fun and more social and
enjoyable because i'm a really social
person and that's definitely something
that's been hard for me in this area of
work
but if you guys liked this video and you
enjoyed seeing me do a fun little collab
please please please give me the thumbs
up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me collaborate with next is
there any other great toronto creators
that you guys know of that i can hook up
with uh don't i mean not that kind of
hookup obviously i'm married um but
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]